[Musique]
bienvenue à la maison chérie
tu sais lire maintenant c'est quoi c'est
confidentiel
je te compagne non je suis désolé tu
n'es pas invité
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais là un gros
problème et il faut que tu m'aides faut
que je change d'amis
c'est le nouveau lui c'est lui notre
sniper inquiète pas j'ai des lunettes de
précision
œil de lynx regarde bien ce visage tire
pas dessus par accident
des terroristes ont volé des missiles
nucléaires qui étaient à bord d'un cargo
si ces bébés sont lancés c'est la
troisième guerre mondiale
tu préfères cette vie à tes amis
à ta famille
[Musique]
on fait tout péter
t'as pas plus gros que ce truc
[Musique]